la parole est à Madame Anne Bergen pour
le groupe démocrate
mesdames le présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Madame Charlotte
CODEL secrétaire d'État auprès de la
première ministre chargé de l'enfant au
cours des derniers jours nous
institutions ont mis les enfants et
leurs paroles à l'honneur que ce soit
lors d'un débat inversé organisé par la
présidentielle brune Pivet avec l'UNICEF
ou avec la tenue d'un conseil des
ministres des enfants présidé par madame
la Première ministre ces événements sont
la preuve de la volonté du gouvernement
d'obtenir de réelles avancées sur la
protection de l'enfance la création
d'une délégation parlementaire au droit
de l'enfant le 13 septembre dernier
présidé par notre collègue Perrine
Goulet démontre cette volonté d'être à
l'écoute de la Parole de la jeunesse
cependant si des progrès significatifs
ont été réalisés ces dernières années
beaucoup restent à faire un rapport de
l'Unicef paru dimanche dernier à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
des droits de l'enfant fait état d'une
situation alarmante un enfant meurt tous
les 5 jours suite à des violences très
majoritaires ment intrafamilial oui vous
avez bien entendu un enfant meurt tous
les 5 jours en France nous ne pouvons
accepter une France ou une partie de nos
enfants sont en danger et ne sont pas
protégés et la notion de progrès n'aura
aucun sens tant que tous les moyens ne
seront pas engagés pour faire cesser ces
situations madame la ministre vous avez
su identifier ces difficultés en créant
un comité
interministériel de l'enfance voici ma
question pourriez-vous nous faire un
retour des échanges suite à la réunion
de ce comité qui a eu lieu hier et nous
préciser quelle mesure vous envisagez
afin de lutter contre les violences
faites aux enfants
et
la présidente madame la députée bergante
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
violences sur les enfants sans tes
mentale danger sur le numérique oui un
certain nombre de signaux restent
extrêmement alarmants l'enfant sait donc
une priorité du quinquennat le président
l'a affirmé le Parlement et le
gouvernement sont pleinement mobilisés
vous l'avez rappelé c'est dans cet
objectif que la première ministre a
réuni hier le premier comité
interministériel de l'enfance au
lendemain de la journée internationale
des droits de l'enfant
avec l'ensemble des ministres concernés
la première ministre a déterminé 5
chantiers prioritaires et une
quarantaine de mesures dont il
n'appartiendra d'assurer le suivi et la
coordination le premier chantier c'est
celui de la lutte contre les violences
faites aux enfants et vous l'avez
rappelé les chiffres sont extrêmement
impressionnants le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald